the whole world is watching the falcon
and the winter soldier continue their
fight against the flag smashers as the
increasingly unhinged john walker
continues to tarnish captain america's
shield
here are some of the easter eggs you may
have missed in the falcon in the winter
soldier episode 4.
in the first act of the whole world is
watching sam bucky and zemo try to get
information on dhonia madani
carly's deceased adopted mother it's a
dead end for sam and bucky as the duo
seem to scare off everyone they come in
contact with
sam does manage to have one brief
conversation with a refugee but he
refuses to give up any
information on dona then we see zemo
outside approaching a group of children
while singing baba black sheep
he dumps a pile of candy in front of
them the same turkish delight he
mentioned to bucky and sam inside the
latvian apartment
he tells a group of kids that the candy
was his son's favorite zemo uses the
sweets as a way to dazzle the youngsters
and get information out of them
it works like a charm the little girl
reveals when and where donia's funeral
will be
while this seems like the sort of simple
clever tactic you might see on an
episode of law and order zemo's use of
the candy actually has a connection to
another fictional universe
turkish delight turkish delight is the
candy the white witch uses and the
chronicles of narnia to get information
out of edmund pevensey
it's edmond's favorite candy but the
white witch's suites are also enchanted
making them impossible to resist
in the whole world is watching we
finally get to see the winter soldier in
all his blade wielding glory
during the high octane fight with the
flag smashers at their home base bucky
shows off his skills notably his ability
to throw and catch a knife by its handle
like it's no big deal
the move is a nod to captain america the
winter soldier with bucky replicating a
movie used on steve rogers during the
street fight scene in the 2014 movie
in the whole world is watching bucky's
knife does a couple more spins than it
does in the film both scenes however
show up just how slick bucky's skills
are
what's with all the knives this display
of skill is yet another instance of the
series referencing the mcu's most
memorable moments
it should also be noted that this moment
shows bucky's growth as a character as
he's not willing to kill which is why he
throws the knife next to his opponent's
head and not through it
back when we first met him in the winter
soldier in contrast he had no problem
with ending the life
and the whole world is watching walker
kills a flag smasher by driving his
shield into his chest
this gives us one of the series most
eerie shots john walker seen from below
as he holds a bloody shield
this specifically invokes a prior moment
in steve rogers history making it all
the more clear how dramatically the old
cap differs from the new cap
in captain america's civil war's final
battle steve uses his shield to smash
iron man's helmet
instead of landing a blow to the head as
the audience expects
cap digs his shield into tony's arc
reactor which puts his suit out of
commission steve easily could have
killed or seriously injured tony in that
moment but that's not who he is
he uses his shield as a way to subdue
his opponent instead of killing him
the falcon in the winter soldier employs
cinematography reminiscent of what's
used in that civil war scene making for
a unique
and potent callback walker doesn't have
a personal history with this flag
smasher as steve does with tony but he
also doesn't have the ability to stop
himself and assess the situation which
makes him highly dangerous
there's a darkness inside of walker
which has been emphasized by the super
soldier
serum running through his veins steve
doesn't have that darkness in him
making him a much better captain america
on all fronts
a shield doesn't belong to you
you don't deserve it check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the marvel
cinematic universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you